le 27 décembre dernier les 27 pays de
l'union européenne lancent conjointement
leurs campagnes de vaccination
la présidente de la commission
européenne hier cela vendeurs leyen
affirme sur twitter c'est le moment pour
l'europe
pourtant au 3 février cette campagne de
vaccination européenne ressemble à un
échec
seulement 3% de la population de l'union
européenne avait reçu au moins une dose
de vaccin un pourcentage loin derrière
israël les états unis et le royaume uni
pourquoi lieu est plus lente la faut
tout d'abord aux précautions prises par
l'union européenne contrairement aux
britanniques et aux israéliens lui a
voulu que les laboratoires soient
responsables juridiquement des effets
secondaires des vaccins
l'union européenne a également voulu
attendre le rapport complet de l' agence
européenne du médicament avant de donner
son feu vert pour une mise en
circulation
et puis la question du prix des vaccins
a donné lieu à de longues négociations
conséquence les vingt-sept se sont
retrouvés englués dans des retards de
livraison
la commission européenne a donc été
obligé de revoir ses objectifs à la
baisse
ursula von der leyen le reconnaît
elle-même l'europe n'était pas prête
pour la production de vaccins en masse
en regardant dans le rétroviseur nous
aurions dû plus penser à la production
de masse et aux défis qu'elle pose
nous aurions dû mettre en garde en
expliquant qu'au début le processus ne
serait pas fluide qu'il y aurait des
hauts et des bas au total l'union
européenne accumule cinq semaines de
retard sur son programme
un délai qui coûterait près de 90
milliards d'euros selon l'assureur
allianz
problème ces 90 milliards représentent
un montant supérieur au versement du
fonds de relance de cette année lieu
vise désormais sur la distribution de
100 millions de doses durant le premier
trimestre 2001 21 soit moitié moins
qu'initialement prévu au deuxième
trimestre de cette année
l'union européenne visera 300 millions
de doses voire 80 millions de plus si le
sérum de johnson and johnson est
autorisée alors cure cela vanderlei
année sous le feu des critiques
emmanuel macron et angela merkel sont
montés au créneau pour défendre la
présidente de la commission
ils ont également réaffirmé leur soutien
à la stratégie vaccinale européenne